you said you sometimes watch Classic
Movies to inspire your songwriting and
you mentioned watching taxi
driver I love that
movie and I think you mentioned that you
wrote a love song based on that movie so
Travis ble for people don't know is uh a
taxi driver and uh he's deeply lonely
what do you think about that kind of
loneliness I think that loneliness is a
product of feeling separate from the
world and separate from others and that
the less you experience that separation
the less you'll feel
lonely how often have you felt lonely in
this way separated from the rest of the
world it's less and less every single
year cuz I work very hard at at it
feeling what a part of the world yeah
just meditating and studying scriptures
and don't you think that I mean isn't
there a fundamental loneliness to The
Human Experience just in what sense that
all the struggles all the suffering you
experienced is really experienced by you
alone is it maybe at the very bottom
it's not it's kind of all the same stuff
you didn't feel alone in 2016
2017 I felt like I lost a piece of
myself that I had given to to somebody
else and I feel like people feel that in
romantic um exchanges whether it's
longterm
shortterm you give a piece of yourself
and then if that person dies or you
break up with that person you feel like
you've lost that piece of yourself which
I feel like is very different experience
than if you just are opening yourself
rather than giving a piece of yourself
you're just opening yourself to somebody
or
something so opening is fundamentally
not a lonely
experience no it's a loving experience
and then losing a piece of
yourself can be yeah because you can't
really you can't lose a piece of
yourself if you
are the same self as every other self
right right so if you see yourself as
together with everybody then there's no
losing yeah yeah yeah it's a beautiful
way to look at it